all right garcelle last year
we confirmed you were coming back to the
show i
warned you season two sometimes tougher
than the first
season how much tougher was this season
well i hate to say this but erica made
it a little less tough on me
orphans and widows it makes you feel
sick
did you know any of this no one knows
the answer
but him if i can say that um
definitely you know this season i felt
like i got my bearings and i was you
know
a lot more comfortable and opinionated
as i always am
and uh i think a lot of fun is going to
be hat and drama of course
let's talk the drama because not long
into filming this season you gave an
interview where you said
and they're coming for me let me just
say that they're coming for me but i'm
ready
who was coming for you and what about
okay well that particular day
dory was coming for me i felt like you
know she had things that she wanted to
get off her chest
rightfully so um so that was where my
head was at that day
okay so you were just in a headspace
that day wasn't necessarily the tone for
the whole season that we're gonna
see what do you think is gonna surprise
the fans about season 11
um i think how much we delve into
erica's unfortunate situation
i think also the new girls you know we
get to know crystal and her heritage and
her background
and then kathy hilton who's a hoot she's
really fun i think she's just great i
mean
her short moments in the premiere are
wild
in and of themselves mistaking you for
her sister
yes you're right not just kyle her
sister
a family member a family member you know
what i think kathy's living on a little
bit
of a different frequency than the rest
of us and that's okay
completely completely that's the way we
like it i want to unpack kind of
everything you just teased there let's
start with your tagline
if you want a starring role in my life
you better drop the act
who's the biggest actor in this group
who needs to drop it the most
everybody's a great actor in this group
everybody should get an academy award
because you know i think sometimes
people put at certain fronts up and it's
not really who they are so i think
everybody deserves an academy award
okay i would imagine the state of the
the world this last year
forced some people to drop that act
because you can't hide behind so much
you can't hide behind so much and that
was one of the things that i'm really
happy about this season is
we get to have conversations um tough
uncomfortable conversations that are
actually happening in the world and i
think
shooting a reality show if you're not
talking about what's really happening in
the world that's a mismark
so i was really grateful that we had
uncomfortable conversations at times
well you step into this season and you
make it pretty known you're not gonna
play the beverly hills bs
and leave the drama of last year behind
i think rina is trying to own it really
quickly so that i don't come for her
so why couldn't you just be there for
her
why couldn't you just let it let the
other girls come out
actually i spoke to the producers and i
said going back the first thing i want
to do is i want to have two sit downs
one with kyle and one with rena because
it was important to me i don't want to
fake it
you know and i feel like with rinna i
had a really hard time because we had
been friends for so long
and to see her treat another friend that
she
has known for so long really was
disturbing to me the way you were with
denise
how can i trust that you won't turn
around and do that to me well i
understand that
you really are holding lisa accountable
to her actions of
season 10 and you flat out say in the
premiere
in this moment i don't like you
describe the journey we're gonna see the
two of you on because
the internet detectives you know poking
around
realized you re-followed kyle you didn't
re-follow rena
on instagram no rana for me
um it's tough because
i felt like she went to a place that was
so unnecessary last season
in a lot of ways i'm not going to
disagree so it was hard for me to get
around that and we're still working
like i mean i told her flat out that you
know trust is
important and i don't necessarily trust
her wholeheartedly
um so during the season you will see us
you know trying to figure it out
some good some not so much do you
believe her when she says
she cares a lot about you
yeah i mean yeah
that was a cautious yeah yeah i mean i
think she wants to
make it right but i don't think you can
make it right over one
you know drinks or dinner right which i
think plays into kind of that concept of
sweeping stuff under the rug i think a
lot of people might think you can talk
about it one time
it's settled for the cameras but this
goes deeper than that
yeah it goes deeper than that because i
really i considered her a friend
you know we did see you and denise
hanging out recently
we just wanted to say hi hello
did you talk at all about kind of the
state of things and how does she feel
about still being talked about on the
show she's no longer a part of
i told her what was happening and i told
her that we missed her but i have to
tell you
she looks happier and younger since
she's left the show
the stress but she's in a good place i
mean i would love to see her come back
yeah i understand why she didn't but i'd
love to see her come back
was there ever a moment where you
thought i'm not going to come back this
group i
i saw what they did to my friend and i
can't operate in this you know
i did i did have those thoughts and
um it's a hard show to do you know
it's it's somebody asking about the reel
and i said with the reel i can totally
be myself
and have my guard down with the with the
housewives it's different because it's
not that type of show
um so it was it was definitely a
decision i mean i don't know how much
longer i'll do it but i'm here now
okay you're taking it one season at a
time yeah exactly
yeah it's not a career thing for me
let's talk about kyle
because there was this moment at the
reunion you came to my charity event
raised your paddle to donate five
thousand dollars to children's hospital
los angeles and never paid
what you better watch what you're saying
that is not true when you unpack it
you're saying this to a black woman
a black woman in a certain position talk
to me about the conversations you had to
have with her and do you think the
message
got across that was the hardest thing
because i don't think she
understood the ramifications of that and
we got to a place where i could
i say this in my confessional i didn't
want to
cuss her out i wanted to educate her and
i think
the way she received it which is how
we've been able to move our relationship
forward well that's good to hear that at
least one
relationship is moving in the right
direction yeah
and you know there's this conversation
happening in the fandom
and the viewers right now looking at as
these casts
introduce women of color into
historically
white groups that there's um
this feeling of being a little bit alone
because they're doing one at a time for
the most part
um and there's not necessarily somebody
who's there who speaks the same language
of moving through life as a minority
where there's a shorthand that you can
kind of
look at each other and share these
moments
did crystal coming into the group change
that at all for you
um a little different experience yeah
different experience but a little bit
and it's funny because i think the
fandom can read my mind
it's just the other day i said i'm tired
of being the only black woman in this
group i'm tired of being
always being the only black one in the
in the room um but crystal did
definitely we were able to have
you know conversations about people
seeing color
and race so um that was nice to be able
to have somebody there to
just sort of share that experience
because i think something that a lot of
viewers didn't realize
until seeing really the last year i
don't think people
white people realize the emotional labor
that people of color
carry day in day out just trying to live
their lives
i'm only gonna say i had a big blowout
about that on housewives this season
for sure i mean i lost my i just
it i had enough i had had enough and i
needed to let it out and i didn't even
realize
i needed to let it out but i did um i
think it's hard i think
if you're not in it you don't understand
but i think
you can no longer use that as an excuse
you know just because it doesn't affect
your life doesn't mean that
it's not happening it's happening to
someone you know
absolutely absolutely
would if another black woman joined this
cast would that
change your point of view about your
future on the show like if you had
i don't want to use the word ally but
somebody who had a similar
lived experience that would be fun
um yeah i mean i think it would you
mentioned this conversation around
seeing color which we saw in the trailer
you don't see color are you serious
it seems that crystal actually
pushes sutton a little bit this season
talk to me about those experiences and
what it was like to see those two
periods go i don't want to say head to
head because it seems like they're
actually meaningful conversations and
not fights yeah
yeah no i think they both rubbed each
other the wrong way like
right out the gate both of them i know
when sutton said i don't see
color 10 15 years ago people would say
that and that would be the polite thing
to say
right because it's like but now you
can't really say that anymore because if
you don't see color then you truly don't
see me
because that's the first thing when you
i walk into a room that's what you're
going to see first
do you feel like the women who were
involved in these conversations grew
from having them learned things from
having them
i certainly hope so i can't speak for
everybody but i know some did for sure
uh well on a lighter note you and sutton
have really become
it seems a dynamic duo over the last
year what was your reaction when you
learned she'd get to hold her diamond in
season 11.
oh my god i felt like she deserved it so
much so when she called me
and she's like you're the first person
i'm calling oh my god i got a diamond we
screamed and hollered it was like
ridiculous
i was so happy because i feel like she
deserves it
she brings it um the fans love her and
she's really authentic she's really
authentic she's not out to hurt anyone
she said you know we all say our little
shade shady remarks but
sun's not out to hurt anybody i don't
think sutton even realized when she's
being shady i think
it's just i don't think so either
but we see in the trailer she seems to
be questioning
erica a lot not believing what erica is
saying
you have a lot of nerve don't talk to me
like that
seriously or what
or nothing right exactly shut up
you have said you're proud of how much
erica has shared with the group and how
she handled herself amongst
everything that was going on but are you
satisfied with the
answers she's provided about all that
stuff you know
i don't know if we know everything i
don't know if we'll ever know anything
and
you know i think sutton came from a
really good place about why she was
asking those questions because
this is big stuff we're talking about
you know
and in a way you got to make sure you
you're protected
because we don't know we're just talking
about it
right it's life-altering stuff and i
think there was even a headline that
came out today that was like
prosecutors will be transcribing every
line from real housewives so
that's what i'm talking about like we
didn't even know going into it that
those
things are a possibility and that's what
sutton brought up
and to me it made perfect sense and
it didn't go well with everybody not
everybody felt the same way
yeah it didn't go well with erica from
what it seems what was your reaction in
the moment
seeing her turn to sutton and grit her
teeth and have that
kind of extreme reaction the thing with
that is i was
next to erica so her back was turned so
you just got the ponies i didn't even
see it i got her ponytail so i didn't
see
how angry she was but it wasn't until i
saw that scene that i was like
wow and then of course sutton got really
upset and as she should that was tough
that was do you believe everything that
erica has told you
i'm gonna plead the fifth with any of
the lawsuits like
did you have a heads up is that why you
got divorced
no i did not i don't think erica knows
everything and
you know it's just a tough spot to be
and i mean who'd want i mean
her life changed drastically in a matter
of
you know days i can relate to that when
i got my divorce it was public is
you know it's hard to live something so
personal
so publicly and being on a reality show
just amplifies it that much more so
i definitely feel for her and most
but i feel for the victims yeah it
wasn't
absolutely true then my heart goes out
to the victims and no one else
do you feel like fans will walk away
with a better understanding at least
because i know not all the information's
there but with more insight into the
everything she went through they'll have
more insight but nobody knows you know
it's not over yet right so nobody knows
but they'll definitely get more insight
into
um what she knows and what she doesn't
and stuff like that but that's her story
to tell yeah well looking ahead to the
everything you know you shot what are
you most excited
for the viewers to experience you know i
want the viewers this year to have
to see us have fun i think last year we
got away there wasn't
as much fun because it was all about
denise and uh
i think we brought some more fun into
the season so i hope you guys get to see
that
and is there anything that the viewers
should be bracing for impact for
or that you're going to be bracing for
impact for i'm bracing
i am holding on right you're buckled in
right now okay
hunkering down
you